then joe biden gets to the meat of the
matter okay the meat of the matter is
that everybody who is not on joe biden's
side of the aisle is a criminal
okay so in the middle this is really one
of the most despicable things that joe
biden said remember this is captain
unity over here this is the great
unifier not a divider he's somebody
who's going to bring us all together he
was going to be a president for all
americans not just americans who voted
for him who agreed with him i said at
the time of his inaugural when he said
unity there are two ways to interpret
unity one way to interpret unity is
unity
well acknowledging diversity meaning we
all have different opinions on this but
we're still brothers and sisters and we
can respect one another that's one way
to achieve unity
we try to do that on the show a lot
right i have conversations with people
on the other side of the aisle
very nice conciliatory conversations
where we clarify what we agree with when
we disagree with and then we go home
friends right we try to do that that's
that's one form of unity and then
there's the other form of unity which is
sit down and shut up because joe biden
wants to do what joe biden wants to do i
think it is perfectly clear at this
point which which kind of unity joe
biden is seeking
he made that absolutely clear last night
in one of the most despicable things
that joe biden has said as president so
he goes and he's attacking glenn young
and again harvard mba
former hedge fund guy
[Music]
glenn young is not a rabble-rouser in
any way shape or form
and
here is joe biden suggesting that glenn
youngkin is equivalent to people who
broke into the capitol building on
january 6th and assaulted police
officers here we go
extremism
can come in many forms
can come in the rage of a mob driven
amount of salt driven to assault the
capital it can come in a smile and a
fleece vest
either way
the big lie is still a big lie
so virginia
show up
that's disgusting and it's truly vile
so you're now comparing glenn youngkin
a candidate for the virginia
gubernatorial seat
who is trying to defend parents from the
school boards and trying to stop
children from being indoctrinated in the
notion that america is systemically
racist and he's trying to get rid of
like the grocery tax you're comparing
that guy to people who broke into the
capitol building
paying for my pens and assaulted police
officers
and then you wonder why the right
just refuses to to
side with the left on anything it's
because of this
i said this the the day after january
6th that after january 6th i said
january 6 was despicable it was terrible
what people did on that day is really
gross attacking police officers criminal
behavior criminals should go to jail hey
i said all of that i also said that this
was going to be used by the left as the
baton's wheeled against everyone who
disagreed
it was going to be used and and this
happened over and over i told this
malcolm nance did this when i was on hbo
with malcolm nancy did this he said it
was 30 000 people attacking the capitol
building it was not
there was several hundred people
attacking the capitol building at best
and that was a minor contingent of
people who were actually at the stop the
steel rally on january 6. i didn't agree
with the people to stop the steel rally
but the the tripartite conflation is
amazing
it went from
the writers are bad to anybody who was
at the rally is a rioter to anyone who
supported trump is a rioter to anyone
who is conservative at all whether or
not you supported trump is a rioter
right this is this is the move the move
is you disagree with me and you're
equivalent to a criminal
and then you wonder why we are paranoid
about you labeling parents domestic
terrorists
of course you're labeling parents
domestic terrorists
because after all if they oppose you
they are domestic terrorists according
to you
glenn youngkin is equivalent to january
6 criminals
right they're all the same
what a what a vile statement by joe
biden but perfectly predictable because
again he is not kindly old joe
he is a he's a pathetic career
politician who has never earned his own
money a day in his life even the period
when he was out of government he was
earning based on the fact that he had
been inside government
he is a leech on the public trust
the president of the united states is
is a career-long manipulator and liar
going all the way back
and the fact that he was ever seen as
this sort of nice guy is kind of
bewildering to me the american people by
the way now agree with this americans
are not in the mood for the joe biden
nice old man routine because they don't
think that he is a nice old man they
think that he is a venal corrupt old
politician which is exactly what he is
who's masquerading as a moderate but
actually acting as a trojan horse for
radical extremist policy
that's what this presidency is and he's
demonstrating it he's out there doing it
there's something
i would say almost tragic
about the
about the sort of images that emerge
from this administration of this this
very
geriatric gentleman
who presents this decaying face
of an authoritarian bureaucracy that
wants to control every aspect of your
life while celebrating itself
it's it's kind of honestly like it's
very sad for our country to have
devolved to this point truly
here's the president of the united
states yesterday jabbering like an idiot
because this is what he does frequently
we're taking a page from terry's book on
his governor and when he'd be governor
next time
we're emerging from this pandemic we
want to expand peak pre-k
for three and four-year-olds millions of
pre-care
i don't even know what he's talking
about i love terry mcauliffe in the
background clapping like he understands
what the hell joe biden just said other
than he wants to make trump with them
prefer available to everyone
right this is the person who wants to
control every aspect of your life this
is the person who says that you the
parent should not control your own
child's education this is the person who
says that if you oppose him and you
oppose any of his policies your
equivalent to people who assaulted the
capitol building and tried to kill the
vice president
that's that's
that's that guy
and when he says that extremism can come
in many forms extremism or radical
political radicalism not terrorism
political rattle radicalism can look
like a daughtering old man who can
barely stumble through a paragraph
and today that's exactly what it looks
like in fact it looks like a bunch of
ridiculous buffoons dancing on stage
and just a quick recommendation to our
politicians don't dance on stage it's
never good i'm gonna have to put
together a compilation of politicians
dancing on stage like some of us know
that we're bad dancers and then unless
explicitly at a concert and pulled up on
stage we just will not dance
and even if that does happen we're
embarrassed that that did happen to me
one time it was very embarrassing uh
when politicians go up on stage and then
apparently volunteer to dance look i
mean look at this you got joe biden in
the middle he's got his coat turned up
because apparently it's cold
and he's bent over
like over himself and then you've got
terry mcauliffe
dancing
like a ridiculous human being i don't
even know what he thinks he is doing
just ridiculous and and all these white
people clapping to themselves
uh uh just just
uh and there's terry mcauliffe doing
the inflatable man outside the car wash
the these are the
honestly honestly god if you vote for
this in virginia you deserve what you
get
uh
i'm i'm with h.l mankin the american
people get what they deserve good and
hard
they're getting in california with gavin
newsom where they voted overwhelmingly
to keep him in office and if you vote
for mcauliffe you deserve what you get
frankly
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment